[Music]
you know they're called suppression
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly
so you say to your wife or you say to
your husband darling let's go out to
dinner and then we'll come back we love
our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real the
leading
development one already suppression
balls
red wave i'm soaking wet already
suppression pulse
suppression balls
[Music]
by david jones is his running mate the
most liberal senator in america
kamala
senator kamala harris
[Music]
democrat kamala
[Music]
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer they're coming
for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank
[Music]
i want to just first of all say i'm so
excited to be here
thank you thank you thank you there is
so much about what comes out of donald
trump's mouth don't be rude that is
designed to distract the american people
from what he is doing every day that is
about neglect
negligence and harmony you are fake
don't be rude and in the midst of this
public health pandemic
we have a donald trump
he knew the deal about coven he had been
informed
that it can kill people that it is five
times as likely to kill as
the flu he knew it was airborne
he knew it could harm children
[Music]
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer they're coming
for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you
coming for you if you are under the age
of 26 on your parents coverage
they're
[Music]
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to this i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
a little now that your uh your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono
and wear your little hat rice
because it's going to be called no free
speech
red chinese communist speak
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs
after all you're gonna love this too
you're gonna make a bomb and i hope they
drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork
but you can't have pork stick that
microphone right up your ass
[Music]
this is highly triggered this is an
extremely triggered
[Music]
and trump's going to stay in there
[Music]
anyway so this is a little peek behind
the curtain
a sound of victory
[Music]
i hear
[Music]
victory
[Music]
i hear a sound of victory victory
[Music]
victory
and secrecies and demonic plans and
networks we break it up and we command
them to be exposed right now in the name
of jesus
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike in the name of
jesus strike and strike until you have
victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be
that we would strike the ground for you
will give us victory god
i hear a sound of abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by
for joe biden um
holding a press conference in europe
um after the first day of the nato
summit and he is going to take
questions and everybody even though he's
going to do it
is going to say oh he's demented and he
doesn't know
anything and you know all of this sort
of stuff so that's what we have
lined up for us today and in the
meantime we have
many many different things to go over
um so i'm really glad that dude that
that you're with me today
where to even start um oh oh let me
mention this
if you're watching on twitch today we
actually have our new intern
kate is in the chat she's tdpskate
for all those people who never have any
idea
how to link their amazon to twitch and
sign up
kate can help you with that so you can
interpret her name two ways
tdps kate or tdp
skate anyway
one of those makes absolutely no sense
whatsoever so if you need help
uh signing up for twitch prime then you
can uh
and please don't harass kate guys please
don't harass kate
all right very good i don't even know
where to start maybe i'll just jump in
with something
as we stand by which is i got a
voicemail
about the entire i don't know if you
guys saw propublica leaked
the tax payments of some of the
wealthiest
people in the united states and they
came up with something called the true
tax rate which they are evaluating
over the change in net worth which
includes unrealized gains
this may not be something anybody cares
about
but i do i i am interested in this stuff
so
uh let's let's just jump in and listen
okay here we go
hi david um i wanted to talk about
financial literacy
in the u.s so there was recently a
pro-publica article i don't know if you
saw it and basically they came up with
their version of a true tax rate
right and i think it was emblematic
of something that's a problem not only
on the right but also on the left and
that's
there's just a complete lack of
understanding
um on how basic uh tax rates or just
anything to do with finance in general
i'm with you so far um
in this country and basically the the
true tax rate they said was that
they you had these billionaires like
bezos and um
and musk and um there were a couple
others i think warren buffett was one of
them
and their true tax rate as
pro publica said was um their
the amount they paid on income
divided by the amount um of wealth that
they had gained
right so that's unrealized gains and
then also the amount of
um the amount of income that they had
gained
so you know for for some of these guys
who like their their
portfolios went up because they were big
stakeholders in their companies
like musk is a great example right tesla
skyrocketed
um their true tax rate was extremely low
is in the single digits
but when you actually look at their
income it was like 25 or 30
and i'm we can we can debate a wealth
tax or something like that but i think
there's a growing issue
um on the left of people who don't
understand
basic economics and as well as on the
right i think it's the exact same thing
on the right when
when people hear oh biden or obama wants
to raise your taxes and they don't
understand
original tax rates and they don't
understand when the tax increases would
um actually kick in for higher income
earners
so i just wanted to hear oh guys i'm
sorry we we already have to uh
i can't believe i oh we have to ban
someone already
for harassing kate and it's someone
who's been banned under about 10
different names already it's
unbelievable what's happening here your
opinion on um
on financial literacy in general okay so
listen this
this person is going on for three
minutes the question's really simple
first of all
the true tax rate that propublica came
up with yes it's based on
something that is not how we tax people
we tax people on realized gains
if your stock portfolio doubles if you
don't sell the stock you don't pay taxes
there's no
we we play we pay taxes on realized
gains
fine now what is is there is there an
exception to that
there is property taxes there is
something called
your assessed value of a property if you
own
a property and you buy it and it's worth
four hundred thousand dollars
you are and it's i'm sorry it's assessed
that four hundred thousand dollars
you pay yearly property taxes on four
hundred thousand dollars
if the value of the property goes up to
five hundred thousand dollars
and the city reassesses it at five
hundred thousand dollars
you immediately are paying more in taxes
even though you have not realized those
gains you've not
sold it for five hundred thousand
dollars it's just been
evaluated as being worth more in the
market and you pay more in taxes that is
with
real estate we don't have something like
that
for stocks and bonds if people want that
then you've got a lobby for it so i
think that the pro publica article
was interesting not because warren
buffett's not doing anything
wrong by not paying taxes on unrealized
stock market gains
that's the way the system is designed
the the illumination that we should have
as if we didn't know it right is the
system favors those earning money from
assets rather than earning money from
labor
when you work and get paid those are
realized gains
you took your labor and you sold it and
you got the money
and now you pay taxes when my tesla
stock doubled
tripled quadrupled you know whatever um
i didn't pay any taxes on it until i
panic sold half of it
when elon musk smoked pot with joe rogan
because i thought
it was going to go downhill from there
when i then sold half of the stock
i paid taxes because i realized the
gains
that's just the way things work okay so
if you want to change that you have to
change that
reality and there is misunderstanding
about it
the true tax rate as described by pro
publica isn't a real thing there is no
such thing
it's just you pay taxes on wages and
unrealized gains
etc um fine so
that's that we've gotten that out of the
way next
i want to say a really big thank you
to anon emus who
just signed up at joinpackman.com with
the coupon code
better21 and his new member number one
today
i also want to thank paco taco
for the twitch sub ericusprime
just signed up on twitch d heart
attack just signed up trisha northstar
just signed up that's four twitch subs
uh we do have
kate the intern in twitch chat today
help if you need help signing up for
twitch prime with your amazon prime
account
you can ping tdpskate she will help you
figure it out it's really not that tough
but we noticed that a lot of people
struggle with it and that's fine we want
to help we are here to help folks we are
here to help
um all right let's see here
s says am i going on rogan anytime soon
via super chat nothing planned
you know for all i know rogan may be
furious with me because i did the clip
about the stuff he said about vaccines i
don't know i haven't talked to joe since
i did that clip
in the clip i said this isn't i'm not
calling out rogan in the sense that you
know i would just have this as a
conversation with him
if i were ever to be back on um
hopefully he uh you know but i mean
i have no idea i have no idea if he will
ever have me back on
he may consider the bridge burned
because of the segment i did or not
or not and uh that would be that
okay what is our discord davidpakman.com
discord that is the discord
also by the oh by the way we are now
getting very very close to our first 5
000 subscribers on the new
youtube channel which is clips from the
streams you can find it
at davidpakman.com slash
pacman live if you sub during the stream
you will actually show up right here
let's see what's on the channel you can
tell it's like the whimsical channel
because my hair looks insane
that's the signal uh that's how that's
how you know
what is the top performing clip so far i
mean it's a small channel still
looks like it's this one 3 100 views
let's check it out first 4 300 are in
right now here we go
into that
i did were you able to get noam chomsky
to purchase some sheath underpants
you know the topic of sheath underpants
didn't come up with noam chomsky i have
to admit
oh i think this is the get off my stream
clip went to in vermont it was like for
jewish people or something she went to a
school hold on a second
she went to a school in vermont that was
for jewish people or something but she
said in the
other voicemail she's never seen someone
being jewish that's not making a lot of
sense to me
and i'm not jewish and they didn't i
died i guess yeah
did you say anything about judaism um
i learned like a little bit about
science and stuff but it was mainly
about poetry and stuff like that wow
jewish school taught mostly poetry
that's interesting
get off my stream all right
okay so that's the top performing clip
right now on the new channel
uh and 20 20 people just dropped in
subscriptions on that new youtube
channel so we're building it up it's
just a new thing
we're trying it out uh we've got a new
thumbnail format that's coming out soon
oh oh by the way
i would actually love your help with
this let me see if i can find it
we are about to hold on thumbnails
let me i don't even know if i can do
this this quickly
um download attachments
yeah check this out we're going to have
a slightly different
thumbnail format for the new channel
and i think people are going to love
this i would love to get your thoughts
on what the right
colors are um
oh geez this is this is actually more
complex than i expected
so the idea is that in your feed if
you're subscribed to both channels
you'll easily be able to figure out
whether it's the live channel which uses
blue
check this out here's here's what we've
got cooking this i'm actually really
pleased with this
hold on a second here we go check this
out so the idea is the
the you the new channel will have a
slightly different format thumbnail
which will be a different ancillary
color and instead of saying
tdps in the upper right it will say pack
live you understand right
so this is amber
this is green this is
orange this is red
this is sea foam this is
yellow okay so
i don't know maybe at some point we
would do a vote of some kind or
something like that but the idea is
to just have thumbnails that stand out
so people will know it's the second
channel
uh let's go back to the beginning so we
have amber looks yellow hilariously and
yellow looks yellow
but this is a slightly different color
so this is amber
this is green this is orange
red sea foam
and yellow um i think these are pretty
slick guys
i think these are pretty slick i'm not
going to i'm not going to lie
so that's something that we have cooking
for the
new youtube channel and lots of other
very very exciting things planned you it
is still
early on it is a nascent channel you can
find it
at davidpakman.com slash
pacman live and uh very very
exciting stuff okay
let's see i do have unban requests to
adjudicate
let me see here oh let me grab my gal
when you get banned on twitch you can
ask to be
unbanned and a couple of people have
done that the first one is a user named
raider dog who came up
and said why is biden's like dislike
ratio
so bad on every video about him on
youtube didn't he get 82 million votes
very stupid comment but not bandworthy
um why does he only get a hundred likes
at the most in
videos featuring him
biden doesn't know where he is then they
were banned
and their unbanned request is hahaha
unban me you nazi liberals that is a
perma-ban my friends
there it is um this this same use
user labontek who's been banned under
about 10 different names so far
made a new username today and showed up
and said i love you david i'm sorry for
the inconvenience
tpskate i need help signing up for
gaming
i need help signing up for gaming
tdpskate [ __ ] you
they were banned and that is just a
perma-ban
it is just like it's like whack-a-mole
it's crazy with this guy
all right what else do we have going
okay so
we've done those very good oh people
wanted me to look at the
kaylie marga nanny clip
where she said she doesn't lie actually
i have that available here
in fact kate shared that with me let me
pull it up
you actually i could just find it on
twitter
let's see mac and nanny never lied
maybe i'll find it that way
okay i never lied
wait what it was like on the view or
something right
okay no let me find it hold on live i've
got my
various folders here kaylee maganny
here it is copy
okay this should be really good
okay kaylee mcinanni claims i never lied
as trump's white house
press secretary cites belief in god
okay oh no this is the original old clip
former white house press secretary kelly
mcinanny proclaimed sunday that her
faith in god
prevented her from ever telling a single
lie how convenient
she spoke to attendees of the
conservative group turning point usa's
young women's leadership summit on
sunday reiterating her claims that she
never lied once
as uh trump's press secretary mcinanny
who was the trump administration
spokesperson from april 20
to january 2021 recalled the may 2020
press conference question in which a
journalist asked her will you pledge
never to lie to us
she responded i will never lie to you
she repeated the claim and said she
can't lie because she's christian okay
let's see
oops looks like we're muted hold on
unmute
you ever lie to us and i said without
hesitation no
and i never did as a woman of faith as a
mother of baby blake
as a person who meticulously prepared at
some of the world's hardest institutions
i never lied i source my information but
that will never
stop the press from calling you a liar
well also the fact that she lied
persistently
is another reason she was called a liar
which is why my dad said kayla you've
got to come up with a motto for your
press shop and i did and our motto was
this
offense only because
[Music]
very powerful very very strong motto
there
she's lying about not lying exactly
because i knew
it's almost like that conundrum uh
this sentence is false right you guys
know that one
what we were up against republicans
always get the bad headlines
always get the false stories always get
the
lies if i can use that word told by the
press
there is one standard for democrats and
another for republicans
and we must be on offense confident bold
and willing to call it
out we cannot be silent yeah she's she's
disgusting
and she's desperate to to
remain relevant quite frankly that's
that's that's what's going on here
that's all that's going on here
let's look at some super chats the
family says
do you think anything will come of these
doj apple metadata scandals all past day
g's denied knowledge of anything
the my first story on today's show
today's podcast
is about that so i don't want to preempt
myself
gt says i just watched the mic pillow
rally stream and i'm disgusted by the
sheriff's unhinged comments
yeah the sheriff was nuts trump also
spoke at the
thing did you guys notice trump's eyes
were almost completely swollen shut
during this thing like look at this
hold on why are trump's eyes almost
completely swollen shut
and then he had technical difficulties
which was really the only good moment
from this thing having a hard time with
the contractors i know contractors
better than anyone they're very
brilliant they may not read or write in
some cases but you know what they're
smarter than the rest
it's water
[Music]
so i just want to thank everybody
yeah thanks everybody i just don't get
the swollen eyes the
the right eye seems completely closed
um i don't know really strange but that
was a wacky wacky event
and then let's look up a clipper to
whoa hold on a second
sheriff clark
see if we can find some videos there
this was before
let's see actual sheriff clark videos
here he is
national level should attach their name
to this bill
or be in favor of it in congress it has
been named the george
floyd police reform act
now i don't know about you but i'm tired
of hearing about george floyd
all right let's see what else he had to
say
um well that's a weird video
do we have are there any other clips
from the maga frank rally
might have to find a youtube video to
get the whole thing
here's an interview with him from before
news mainstream media it's our education
system
all of that you know on top of what we
saw with
kovid and the lockdowns and and just you
know attacking our elections and all of
that
how the heck do we take where we're at
now
and get our country back well you know
we need to sift through the ruin first
of all
and and take a look at how they did it
so that they can't repeat those same
tactics again
well they saw that that worked i mean
think about it they got
350 million americans to
wear face covers you couldn't get no you
didn't
first of all there's 331
30 40 of them never wore a mask this guy
needs a
it's just simple arithmetic 350 million
americans to do anything
and they were able to do that through
fear and intimidation
so we have to stop being afraid you have
to recall that
you know the beginning of this country
started violently to the american
revolution
all right and all throughout our history
we've had to have periods of violence
that's what war is war is violence so
here he's alluding to we might need to
do violence again just
just casual calling to violence of the
people that follow this guy
yeah we had two world wars we had the
civil war to free the slaves bloody 500
600 000 americans lost their lives
sometimes brother against brother
family against family in the civil war
you look at the war
to stop the spread of communism in
southeast asia that's what the vietnam
war
was about and you can go on through uh
you know the wars in the middle east
it was all about defending freedom so
somebody
and a lot of somebodies lost their lives
the war in iraq after 9 11 happened
which iraq had nothing to do with was
about defending freedom that's weird
fighting for this country it's not
enough to just talk
it's not enough to just [ __ ] and
complain
people are going to have to realize that
they're going to have to take an active
role
yep so these are calls to violence you
know they're coded
sometimes sometimes more coded sometimes
less coded
but they are uh they are indeed calls to
violence so that's
that's i mean this is nutty nutty stuff
really really nutty stuff
i want to say thank you to tiny aim for
subscribing via twitch prime also thank
you to grungy dan
for the subscription thanks to billy
carpenter
and lee lee mw
legrand pizza has also signed up uh 10
folks signing up via twitch
today we do have a helper in the twitch
chat
our new intern kate is there tdps kate
if you need help
if you have amazon prime you can sign up
for twitch prime for free
you're taking money from bezos's pocket
but you've got to know how to do it it's
really easy
and tdps kate is in the chat
and can help you out a few other super
chats coming in
race the turtle says david here's ten
dollars please never play any mackinani
audio for us ever again she's
intolerable
fair connie says what's
the girth of your biceps looking swole
lately
yeah 30 35 inches i think
about 35 um
all right thank you very much okay
let me see if i can get to
i have some of these let me see how i
can do this
this is going to be tough to do
so one of the one of the contests we're
running right now
are um it's a contest for like the new
intro video for our new channel clips
and this is for the pacman live channel
of course
and we've gotten a bunch of interesting
submissions let me see if i can just
play
some for you hold on
so yeah okay good here's one
possibility anybody can design these
we've started getting these in
let's see i need to frame them all
correctly
yikes this is this is really tough to do
ah there we go all right here's one
possible introduction
for the live channel youtube clips all
right take take a look at this
right it's just a three second let's
play it again
that's not bad okay that's a pretty good
one
let me play another one for i really
should have had these prepared in a
better way
i'm sorry that i don't uh here let's
look at
another one here
[Music]
that's it that's the whole thing
okay that one's not quite as good
um let's see
intro submission i've not pre-screened
all of these
so we're all seeing some of these for
the first time
that's not bad okay let's look at it
once more
not bad that's not bad right
it's very it's uh it's branded from the
standpoint of audio
let's look at another one
okay all right not bad it's a more
professional approach
no no audio element which is fine but
that's not bad
let's look at another one
huh that one appears to be some kind of
invalid file
then they sent another one let's see
yeah this one just doesn't even work
weird all right and let me see if i've
got any others here's one more
um this is i think this is a little too
similar to
also this font is not one of our fonts
okay
so far i think the first one might be
the best one
let me see if i have any others no
that's all i've got so far
yeah i i do think the best one right now
is
where was it
i think it's this one right
that's the best one i think it's i think
it's pretty clear so far
you can still get yours in ideally
upload them to youtube and send
me the youtube link and then we will
have like an official contest at some
point
okay so very very good all right
other super chats coming in
do you agree with aok that morally
billionaires
shouldn't exist or wealth should be
capped um
morally billionaires shouldn't exist no
i no i no that not really i mean
there should be very few billionaires
and they should be heavily taxed
and the wealthier you get the more you
should be
um sort of recommitting back to society
but billionaires shouldn't exist i don't
know i'd have to be convinced of that
see there's so many things that we can
do to just improve
circumstances that going on a wild goose
chase of
make billionaires illegal it's like okay
guys we there's so much more that we can
do that we could actually accomplish
rather than figuring out a way to ban
billionaires that it's hard for me to
seriously engage with it because we're
so many layers removed from that even
being a serious
discussion um yeah
christopher like says lots of ahas at
the rally
uh-huh uh yeah i know i saw it will the
democrats be able to pass voting reform
before 2022
worried about all these goofy voting
suppression laws in red states i am
worried that democrats
will not be able to pass voting reform
aaron cooper says i wanted to get your
opinion of trump's claims on
hydroxychloroquine that he was correct
all along
i've seen no evidence of that whatsoever
daddy longneck says you take a lot of
instagram selfies bro
narcissism much
that is a sick burn i don't know how i'm
ever going to recover from that in fact
i should delete my instagram because
that is i i think that that could
be disastrous to the show um
oh my god i should even get it off
screen i don't want people to see that
and then the show might end up canceled
okay i'm gonna cover up that super chat
guys because it's so devastating to
everything i'm doing
please never send a super chat like that
again okay
definitely not for two dollars it's just
absolutely terrible
okay somebody did something pretty funny
this is an edit of a phone call i took
last week i
i think this is edited to be cardi b
calling in although i don't really know
um this is the edit that was done i like
this
oh poor it as hell i live it with my
ex-boyfriend that was beating my ass
i had to drop out of school i was like
um living with his mama two peoples
and a bedroom how's i gonna leave if i
only made 200
every week ain't no way
bleak i'm not gonna lie but listen we
still have memes right we at least have
that
no was that an insensitive reaction to
cardi from me
i mean she told me this horrible story
and then i just say at least there's
memetics
i live in with my ex-boyfriend that was
beating my ass i had to drop out of
school
i was like um living with his mama
two pitbulls and a bedroom
how's i gonna leave if i only made 200
every week
yeah ain't no way
it's bleak i'm not gonna lie but listen
we still have memes right we at least
have that
no so there it is cardi b calling into
the show
uh nicely nicely done by the way has the
press conference been rescheduled
because it was supposed to be five
minutes ago
and washington post says it's not for
another 40
does anybody know for sure let's see if
i can find this out
biden press conference june
14 39 minutes would be
1 35 p.m what a weird time
one hour ago
i can't even tell
yeah i don't know but we'll keep an eye
i mean it's no big deal we have plenty
to do i'll just keep the volume up here
so we hear it
okay yeah no i would be open to opening
the phone lines if people want
but we're gonna have to make some
headway here my friends we do have a
coupon code
mikepillow50 it's a leftover coupon code
from uh the mic pillow rally
you can use that to sign up at
joinpacman.com mikepillow50
and my prediction is that with that code
this is just going to skyrocket
i also want to thank people who signed
up on twitch including
tuckle yeah tuckle
oh tuckle gifted a subscription to our
intern tdps kate that's nice
and then rocket9 also
signing up putting us at 12. if you need
help figuring out how to sign up via
twitch prime
tdpskate in the twitch chat
can help you out okay
other super chats did you see
mcconnell's comments today yes that he
would block
a uh supreme a supreme court nomination
in 2024
guys of course he would there's not
what's the surprise it's mcconnell of
course you would
woodix says what do you think of the
nightmare scenario where trump is
speaker and with a gop controlled house
and senate he systematically impeaches
until he is the successor not going to
happen my friends
cabana boy says i heard you were a
prolific dater in college tiger
what do you care my friend what do you
care denver mccarthy says now is a good
time to take a short
break cut to an ad for home driveway
theft insurance yeah listen sometimes
people's driveways are stolen
please call driveway insurance mutual of
of
omaha they will make sure that that
doesn't happen
can anybody help me find that rudy ad
where it's like an ad for an insurance
for a situation that would never happen
rudy insurance sponsor let me see if i
can find this
it's unbelievable oh rudy
it's like a title theft thing
does anybody know where i can find that
actually i guess i could go to rudy
giuliani youtube
i sort of remember
oh is rudy suspended i think he is
what's the name of his show
man it's so hard to find anything
the show was common sense or
god i just don't even have i have no
memory of what it was
rudy having yeah
rudy's common sense
rudy giuliani's common sense
oh here it is hold on
it was one about i think abortion or
something
rudy's common sense
i don't even know what the website is
for what's his own website this is just
crazy
2021 podcasts
wasn't school choice he interviewed a
random person about living with a
communist oh here it is
okay hold on we're getting to it we're
getting to it you have you have to check
out this ad that rudy
does it's a it's a it's a it's a problem
nobody would ever have
let me see
that will not criticize china no this
isn't it
where did he get to this ad
it's it's just stunning
fight socialism okay hold on here it is
help build my pillow into the entrance
oh no this is the my pillow ad hold on
crap where is that
it might have been earlier right it
might have been like up here no this is
the silver ad
okay
oh here it is go to home title here it
is
check this out this is an amazing ad
because it's going to take a short break
it's something nobody needs
your credit card company found
suspicious charges on your card
that simple identity theft it's annoying
but they cover it
the type of fraud you really need to
worry about is home
title theft i have never heard of this
happening to anyone
i've literally never heard of that
happening to anyone i know
five real estate lawyers they've never
mentioned that it's ever something
they've heard of happening
a devastating crime that takes you off
your home's title
it takes you off your home's title not
covered
by insurance or most identity theft
programs
that's why you need home title mock
right here's how easy it is for cyber
criminals to get you
the title documents to our homes are
does it really require
coding to steal a title like it seems
the type of thing you would do by going
to the registry not like i don't know
why the guy is writing code
in order to steal a title online the
thief
forges your signature on a quick claim
deed stating
you just sold your home right like why
do you need to code to form forge's
signature and he's the new owner
then he borrows money using your home's
equity and leaves you
in debt you won't know until late
payment or eviction notices arrive
the instant home title lock detects
someone tampering with your home
they help shut it down let's get you
protected
go to the home title lockdown so anyway
the scam is that i don't think that that
would ever happen
you know i wasn't able to find anybody
who's even aware of that
ever having happened it's very very
strange
um okay
i told my friend i own my pillow and i
love it he laughed and said the pillows
aren't the problem i agree
a guy named bald balls is asking a
really stupid question
lee douglas says went inside original
air force one at museum of flight
thoughts on air force one
no i don't i don't have you know i don't
know anything about it
also a new air force one in 2024 what
would you put in your own
private jet plane i would get title lock
insurance for it because somebody could
steal
uh the title to my plane and then all of
a sudden i'd be um
i'd be completely screwed okay all right
so that is that
let's now get to this is something i'm
going to be covering on today's show
here is a supposedly registered nurse
who says that vaccine trials for covid
have been like nazi experiments done on
jews and concentration camps take a look
we're not going to say this is nearly as
big as the holocaust was but
at the beginning the way they did make
people have trials and injections
medications
procedures against their will this is
pretty much what they're doing right now
they're having forcing people to take a
shot when
nobody's being forced to take a shot
they don't want to and they're not
giving the proper informed consent like
this is called giga yikes nobody is
being told the risk factors before
getting this injection
untrue i got like a three-page pamphlet
and they checked my medical history and
went on and on and on and on
everything is there anything here that
is um true that this woman is saying
okay i just want to be clear though i
mean you do realize
that there is no comparison here to the
holocaust right i mean
the nazi doctors held medical
experiments
on people and some died some i mean it
was painful it was awful
how could you even compare it to that
right i i didn't compare to the whole
well you did
but i did compare to the beginnings of
it which is the nuremberg trials
so this is so funny the nuremberg
nuremberg trials happened after the
holocaust from 1945 to 1946
now someone sent me a funny tweet about
this it almost sounds like she thinks
the nuremberg
trials were medical trials that happened
like it it's almost like she thinks the
nuremberg trials were
the experiments done on jews like
exposing them to
cold temperatures and all of this stuff
because
the the nuremberg trials themselves
happened
after the holocaust
so when and she's talking about medical
trials and tests
do you guys think she means that by
nuremberg trials she means
that they were medical trials it's it's
one of the stupidest things i've ever
heard
what a disgusting person um
yeah she seems to think that she seems
to think that very very strange stuff
so that's that they were tribunals
exactly they were essentially tribunals
all right all that sudafed had trump
looking like
gothmog from lord of the rings i've
never seen lord of the rings i mean i
saw
10 minutes and i had to check out it i
noped right out of there so i don't know
what that is
trump would try and use title lock to
steal back the white house that's
the brilliant bay photo the only person
i can imagine trying to steal
title is trump himself to get himself
back in the white house beautifully done
jacob ratner says sir after trump
refusing a peaceful transition of power
and january 6 have we crossed a rubicon
with political violence in the united
states is there a risk of sectarian
violence in the future
i believe that the answer is yes and
when i say it some people say i'm being
hyperbolic i don't believe it is
hyperbolic
i believe that it is a very real risk
serge says david i got kaiser what did
you get i got moderna it's all the same
guys
it's all the same it really is you know
everybody likes to have a hot take
about the difference between one and the
other it's really all the same
do you guys want me to do voicemails or
a review a revisit of my old interview
with milo
yena minopolis which would people prefer
the milo interview or voicemails
a lot of people calling for milo
all right or it seems like it's
overwhelmingly people going for milo
okay so let's do this
let's check out the milo interview a
little bit we have some time before
biden comes on
so if we fill this let let's even if we
get to
50 website members i will open up phone
lines if we have time before biden
just sign up at joinpacman.com there's
there's two
coupon codes that i would be careful
about but they work felony 21
and mike pillow 50. you can pick
whichever one you want
felony 21 or mike pillow 50.
and of course you can sign up via twitch
but let's get right into it this was my
interview with milo yiannopoulos as i
told on
on the show last week i exchanged some
emails with milo milo
has come out as heterosexual now and um
i invited him on the show to talk about
it and he said no
so all we can do is go back to my old
i'm joined today by milo yiannopoulos
who is an associate editor
at breitbart the reason that milo is
here is to follow up on what
i guess yesterday marked the start of
our coverage of gamergate
and to quickly get people up to speed as
to where we are now at least from the
purposes of our show
gamergate is this online movement for
lack of a better term
there are those who believe that
gamergate is a kind of a consumer
movement against what some see as fraud
nepotism cronyism by the way
gamergate oh the stupidest stupidest
okay anyway within the video game
industry
there are others who see gamergate as a
misogynistic and sometimes even racist
or xenophobic movement
designed to keep whether it's women or
minorities or other
groups out of the video game world
yesterday i interbrewed brianna wu who
is a video game developer
she made a very specific allegation
about an interview with milo that did
not happen
and milo is here to address that so milo
let's start at the beginning
how did you first get involved with
gamergate
well i wasn't previously a gamer in fact
i'd said some relatively disobliging
things about gamers in the past
but i kind of got sucked into this issue
because i saw
uh if you like a marginalized community
the gaming community being accused of
some things that it obviously extremely
marginalized community
you know uh when they came for the jews
and i said nothing
then they went for the romani when they
went for the romanian i said nothing
then they came for the
african-americans and then eventually
they went for the gamers he had not done
uh and having its art form having its
its hobby trashed by people who were
obviously in it for
ulterior motives and it's sort of it i
guess it raised my journalistic heckles
if you like
uh because i sort of this uh injustice
if you want to put it like that going
on and thought i'll take a look into
this and as time has gone by i've
become i guess the sort of default
reporter for all this
okay and is your position that you are a
a pro or anti on this issue or do you
see yourself i know that you wrote in
the blog post
about your interview with brianna woo
which didn't happen you wrote
i am a reporter and not a member of the
movement
and thus imagine having cared about this
you know and it's like uh
i am well placed to bridge the divide
between the pro and the anti-side
do you still stand by that that's your
position within gamergate
absolutely and i think it's perfectly
fair and you can see that not only from
the interactions that i have on both
sides of people but also um
people have been doing these incredible
uh maps of um
you know the gamergate universe they do
this great number crunching and data
analysis of the tweets and you'll see
that there are
people who are able to speak to both
sides of this debate slap bang in the
middle of this
this great uh sort of connections map
um people like christina hoff summers
the american enterprise institute
and um are right in the middle uh
geographically speaking of both groups
it's also like it's really mostly about
gamergate which is so bad for us
let's skip to the end because i think i
just in a desperate move to try to make
it remotely interesting
i asked him about trans issues i
i i think that happened let's places
that she uses yes absolutely i'm saying
that okay
because to me in my opinion is it didn't
read like a satire piece last thing i
want to say about this you mentioned
transsexualism being a mental disorder
the fact that there is something called
gender identity disorder which is uh uh
diagnosed so to speak in some
individuals who feel that
their uh physical gender does not match
the gender they feel they are
that's different than saying this is
equivalent to psychopathy for example by
the way give me a break guys on the
terminology i'm using this was seven
years ago obviously now i have much more
sophisticated language for discussion
discussing trans issues i think that
you're treading on dangerous ground we
may just disagree on this right
yeah i know the sorts of diseases that
it's closer to um are things like
uh i mean there are patients um at johns
hopkins which is the
the university hospital the pioneer
transition surgery um they have a they
have a um
award which deals with a lot of these
sort of related conditions there are
patients who believe that their arms
don't belong to them they wake up one
day and they think their arm is no
longer part of their own body
there are patients who believe that they
are dead that they wake up and they're
clinically dead
um the basis of my argument is that what
we don't do is warp reality to conform
to those delusions with those kinds of
disorders we give people therapy and
drugs to help them reconcile reality
with their with their minds
um that's a very uh commonly accepted
treatment path for those sorts of
disorder my contention
is that transgenderism falls into that
category of disorder
okay and to be clear this is just an
assertion that you're making
well it's based on so it's based on
reading the science it's based on
reading and science from uh from johns
hopkins which is the first
university to really pioneer transition
surgery which no longer performs that
surgery
because it has a sufficient body of
patience to know that
that most of these people very
tragically kill themselves with or
without the surgery and there's some
some reason to suppose that people who
have the surgery
are even more likely to kill themselves
it's a treatment plan that doesn't work
um and it's something that's become a
holy cow because i think because
transgender people
have uh been bracketed in with gays and
lesbians as part of the sort of
lgbt civil rights bloc you know what's
interesting about this is there
is a lot of anti-trans in the gay
community now i know milo
i guess isn't gay anymore but he was at
the time i didn't you know
okay um so we have we now wrongly
consider
um transgenderism to be just the next
civil rights frontier i don't believe it
has anything
uh in common with gays and lesbians
whatsoever i understand that some people
will find that offensive well in the
same way that many people would find
that
there's many people who disagree that
the issue of
uh gay and lesbian rights has anything
at all to do with the struggle for
uh african-american rights in this
country and there are people who
disagree
so people are on a spectrum on this no
question about it
with that view too um i don't think
those people are entirely wrong i think
it's a debate that we ought to have but
that for various reasons we're not
really allowed to
all right so listen milo we're totally
out of time
yeah so anyway that was that now if you
want to see now
uh he's been doing he's he's no longer
gay i guess
and um he's been doing these interviews
with
true news man i don't even know if i
want to get into this but it's
it's pretty freaking nuts here here's
one that he does
with this guy and we weighed it
we waited for the hit piece yes and we
weighed it let me guess
can i take a guess yes never appeared it
never appeared never appeared
and i i asked him several times where's
your hit piece yeah where's the
piece and he told me the editors
wouldn't print it
this is now i guess ex-gay milo i don't
know
what do you think happened milo i know
exactly what happened because i've been
through this myself
so many times
when somebody spends time around you
around your family around your team now
he's being introduced as a christian
do you see that best-selling author and
christian
company as if that's a credential um as
i'm sure
well as i know has been the case with me
too it's not
so difficult really to charm people who
are essentially fairly simple and
charmless journalists
and they find themselves sort of taken
with you um
what by the way yeah what awards you
know i jokingly i jokingly say hey you
know
you should really get a membership
because you get access to the
award-winning bonus show and i admit
they're all awards
i give out like the value of an award i
give my own show is
is minimal what awards has milo gotten
it's it's it's
wild when i've had journalists embedded
with me for two or three days by the end
of it they've been making passes at me
um and just get rid of your
publication and say well actually i kind
of want to write a bit more of a nuanced
piece he's not quite this he's not quite
that the editor
will turn around and say never mind um
i hired somebody uh once upon a time all
right anyway
so let me see if i can find the clip
where he does his uh
let's see milo true news
he's doing this whole thing
okay yeah this is no that's not the one
i wanted to show there's one where
like his appearance is just bizarre i
guess it is on this
show let's let's check it out um yours
was christianity month yes
it's not quite catchy enough is it of
course it is i like jihad june
man what is this about and then i guess
he was interviewed by
someone named baked alaska
by the fbi because you did let's be
honest
tiptoe no no baked alaska's interviewed
by milo i don't know
who what is what is this on a
sightseeing mission you went for a
little museum
also is milo's audio doubled i feel like
i'm hearing his audio doubled like
there's a big tech issue
museum trip on january the 6th yes you
did but
the thing that made me really want to
talk to you today was you told me
um uh by text the other day that uh
in writing the fbi is coming for you
over a
tweet can you just can you just talk us
through i just wasn't this guy in the
capital riots i don't even
i don't even want to put this on i just
i just can't even put this it's just too
it's too much
it's too disgusting i just can't i can't
do it sorry guys
we're not gonna do it okay um some other
super chats coming in
would you support a law that requires
news stations to contain
more than 25 opinion
versus actual reporting
no i not even i unders i don't even know
that i understand that i would not i
don't think i would support that
i don't think if i understand it
correctly i don't think i would support
that
okay as we stand by for joseph r biden
jr
let's get to some voicemails there are a
lot of voicemails to get to
let me just get to where my new
voicemails
start uh okay
here we go let's see
we're gonna skip this one this is like
you know normal voicemails
here we go hey david um
i have a friend who thinks that
colonoscopies are bad
and uh oh it's already getting crazy and
that um
mainstream doctors are not good for
society because
he thinks that you have to go back
multiple times
he's that sort of person who thinks that
alternative
medicine is the solution
and i have the feeling that he's not
thinking critically
and also he's the type of person or
actually he is
um you know physically disabled
and thinks that um what has happened to
him in the past is because of mainstream
doctors
so he has the inclination that that
alternative medicine is the solution
what would you say to people who are
i guess not thinking critically and
automatically assume
the worse when it comes to i mean listen
it's like people that want to think
homeopathy is real
it's very hard to talk them out of it so
i don't know that i would talk too much
to them i would just try to
maybe live your life i that that's i i
don't know that's
i don't know what i would say to that
person that seems like a real problem
all right let's see a couple of other
voicemails here
see what is on people's minds
eric from massachusetts called in again
hey david it's eric uh from mass again
i'm just
um trying to help you out so you don't
look foolish
but um the united states was made into a
corporation under wardrobe wilson
um many years ago and on july 4th
2020 uh donald trump dissolved that
corporation
[Laughter]
what is this guy talking about listen
david um
it was the united states was made a
corporation what
oh what's going on and what he's saying
is
actually you're right you're right uh
trump won't be the president of
america as a corporation he's brought it
back as
a republic like we were before
so basically biden is the president of
nothing
when you say reinstated i don't know if
that's the right war i see
biden is the president of a corporation
that no longer exists
that's pretty that's pretty edgy
all right let's see what else has been
going on
um here's an anti-crypto message let's
listen to that
hi david i would like to know why you're
sort of on board with cryptocurrency
it's been around for about 10 years as
far as i can tell and i haven't seen one
one sort of compelling reason why i
should use it or why it's making the
average person's life easier
or why it's more advantageous than cash
or credit or apple pay
what i do see is that it's used for all
sorts of illicit things
and it's uh it's a new thing for uh
phishing and ransomware and all those
militias well listen
you know most crimes that involved money
are being committed with u.s dollars the
vast vast vast
majority so that's kind of like just
first of all
as far as you don't see why you should
be involved with it then just don't be
involved with it you know
now this could be somebody who's just
mad that they missed out on a 50 000
return if they had bought some bitcoin
you know at the beginning
or maybe they genuinely just don't
understand it or don't want anything to
do with it
don't i'm i'm not trying to convince
anybody to do anything i've i've been up
front i bought a
some bitcoin years and years and years
ago
and i held it and now it's worth a ton
more
and i sold a bunch of it and i have no
idea what's going to happen it might end
up being worth zero
but you know i've diversified like four
percent of my
assets into crypto and it's very
speculative
it is essentially a form of gambling and
that's it i mean you know why is
everybody so mad i mean
just don't don't don't get any crypto
then man don't call me
man who am i
okay let's listen to a couple of others
uh what else do we have here i'm sc i'm
looking at transcripts and skipping
stuff a lot of people just give so much
information about themselves as soon as
they call in
here's the eggman calling in again with
another mask
rant hi dave since most of us are
vaccinated and the cdc says we don't
need
masks anymore when you say that you'll
wear one just to make
other people more comfortable yep yeah
i'm an idiot
guys i'm a cuck okay i'm wearing it just
to make other people comfortable
because i don't want it all over twitter
hey
the one person not wearing the mask in
the store
was david pakman okay i don't want that
i uh i bought bitcoin at like uh please
don't clip this
i bought bitcoin at like four thousand
something like that okay um
you know it's like i was just i was just
on martha's vineyard last week
each of my first three days someone came
up to me and said hey
david pakman i love your show picture
you know nice people
you think if i if i stick my head into a
store and i see everybody's wearing a
mask
i want to be the only person without a
mask so that ends up on twitter
and then it could be even if everybody
else is wearing a mask the person could
post and say
this is video from may of 2020 in the
middle of it
david pakman was the only person in the
place refusing to where you think i want
that
come on guys is that not
virtue signaling 100
shalom brother i do love you guys but
man stop wearing those masks because
you want to make other people
comfortable you're making other people
perpetuate their need to wear a mask
we don't have to wear them anymore and i
know liberals are saying
hey wear them i'm not going to shame you
i am the liberal
that's shaming you for wearing a mask
still i know i'm horrible but
dude stop doing this and then more
people will stop doing this
we're not getting covered we all got the
shot okay shalom brother i love you guys
don't wear a mask anymore indoors that's
silly i love you bye
all right all right all right hello
magman um
yeah i mean listen guys i uh it's it's
it's fine it's just the masks are slowly
coming off
the grocery stores where last week
99 of people had a mask on
now it's 80 percent and even a couple
employees are no longer wearing masks
and they're coming off but just don't
don't worry about it just do whatever
you want
and i don't want to end up on twitter as
the one person not wearing the mask all
right
everybody just relax it's crazy i want
to say thank you to
little blue doggy for subscribing via
twitch
prime i also want to say thank you to
greater candle for resubscribing with
twitch
new members number of 14 sorry 13
and 14 today if you are an amazon prime
subscriber you can get a free twitch sub
free free free just connect your amazon
prime account to twitch and if you need
help doing that tdps kate
kate the intern is in the twitch chat to
help people out
i also want to say thank oh hold on i
also want to say thank you to
teresa wayne scott teresa wayne scott
just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
with the coupon code
felony21 that code is available to you
i would encourage you to use that code
it is not actually illegal
it is not actually illegal felony 21
saves like an ungodly amount of money
off of a membership um a couple other
oh hold on let me get a couple super
chats ashkey says david please tell
biden to hold up important e3 conference
is happening yeah he should how dare he
zachary says i meant limiting the amount
of opinion a news station can
use absent actual facts no no no that's
it's no i'm not for that
i'm not for that uh okay
press conference starting shortly very
good
let's look at a few other voicemails
here
um what do we got
lyft driver
what else maybe some spanish voicemails
looking for something interesting
hmm
what do we have what do we have
hi david this is melissa from california
i have a idea if she's an anti-vaxxer
she probably didn't even get vaccinated
so why would the key
stick to her in the first place oh yeah
that's related to that weird hearing
last week
um yeah that's a fair question that's a
fair question
let's see what else we have
um another voicemail about vaccines
there's a lot of vaccine stuff coming in
i'm kind of getting over the vaccine
stuff
democrats majority
correction about the chomsky interview
man a lot of really kind of pedantic
stuff
um
okay let's listen to this hey david this
is billy from kentucky
i just wanted you to know that i
appreciate you saying trump's going to
be back in office in august it's about
time that the democrats start
acknowledging it
what uh
i watch your show quite a bit i don't
think it's sarcasm i think you really
mean it so
um trump will be in in august and i'm
glad that you're saying it
and i'm showing it to all my democratic
friends
so thank you sir for doing that at least
he's calling me sir
that's polite
maybe you'll play my message on air
i'm just kidding i can't stand trump
hopefully you didn't hang up before you
heard this
so keep doing what you're doing brother
i love it keep sarcastically assaulting
him
love it it's a beautiful thing to watch
you do all right we stuck with it guys
and there was a good path we stuck with
it until the end that's a nice thing
um let's see what else we've got um
the anti-semitic caller i guess now is
on an anti-lawyer rant
david i hate lawyers
the reason why stuff like this happens
is because people are out working
because they can't spend their own money
because people are hoarders
and haters and i hate lawyers because
they're the biggest [ __ ] haters
ever wow brutal attack on the legal
industry that's interesting
um and here's one more
of these insights so what i was thinking
of
is that we need a female buddha and i
think it would be really great
because hey the second get behind female
buddha okay
all right i'm listening i think that
western civilization is really messed up
because
the women are elevated to a point
because they're like
you know taking pride in ruining
generations of people
that i i don't know what that means but
and i just
feel like you know maybe some southern
comfort
is what the united states needs and what
the world needs
and like a female buddhist wait hold on
female buddhist or female buddha those
are two very different things
they're just like that kind of
acceptance in the world
that um you know there's a philosophy
that women should be able to use in the
world
to where we're successful and happy okay
yep all right i'm checking out
i think that that's basically it guys
um from the standpoint of voicemails
i don't think i have any more for you
let me just check one other
one other little enclave where sometimes
some voicemails hide
oh there are a couple more hold on let's
just see no
no this is a no i can just tell very
quickly from the duration in the
transcript whether it's something we
want to play
uh let's see
oh this might be interesting hold on hey
guys this is nina from kansas city
the 33 year old cop you know um i got
i got vaccinated um i i think it sucks
he died
because uh they could have gave him ivor
mexican you know that's the one drug oh
okay all right we don't know anything
about that yet yeah i'm not we're not
gonna
we don't just promote drugs on this show
um
just off of off of a way amount of
voicemail so we're not gonna do that
and i think that that basically gets us
to the edge okay good so that's it as
far as
as far as voicemails are concerned i
appreciate that i do want to say thank
you to
alice madawichas who has just signed up
with prime
has been subscribed for two months
also thanks to hopeful flipper and
the be dizzle all of whom just signed up
via twitch today
also want to say thank you to maria
brittala
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code felony21
and thanks to nicole tercik who just
signed up on my website
also using the coupon code felony21
very much appreciate that as we are
standing by
for joe biden just moments away a few
other super chats
sir if we charged people for the jab do
you think more republicans
would be less conspiratorial around it
as well as boost support of socialized
healthcare
love the show maybe not a reason to do
it but maybe
what is your voicemail why is your
voicemail becoming more like
therapy sessions for these people i
don't know no but you're you're on to
something
do you think if they got rid of the dark
money clause in hr1 it would pass
no i don't think that's even close to
the only thing holding it up by any
means
and mike says david are you worried that
during the fall of 2021 and winter 22
covid will surge among anti-vaxxers
causing the return of restrictions
yes i am indeed worried about that
i think that that is completely possible
absolutely and completely possible yeah
um
and in fact yeah we're
you know we're seeing the growth of
variants now
the point is among vaccinated people
it's not really making a difference
and on wednesday i'm going to be joined
by the great dr ashish
ja or ja and
we will talk to him about that ferret
queen asks when august gets here and
trump's not in office
where do you think they'll move the goal
post they'll have to move the goal post
into the
into the parking lot um
yeah but they're not going to have a
choice at that point there was one other
clip i wanted to play for you guys
yeah check this out this is like the
worst of the worst
of stereotypes about argentinians this
is a clip of the argentinian president
loved by many leftists so big leftist
big leftist
saying that you know argentinians are
really different than other latin
americans because
the mexicans came from indians and
brazilians just came out of the jungle
but argentinians
we came from europe on boats it's so
xenophobic it's so disgusting i'll put
on
um auto translated captions but i can
also kind of explain it to you
this is so
hold gross i wanted to get the subtitles
in auto
translate to english here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this guy's disgusting and insanely
corrupt
[Music]
really
so if you're if you weren't reading the
subtitles what he's saying is
uh octavio pass he's quoting octavio
pass but it's like he he wouldn't be
saying it if he didn't believe it
he's basically trying to ingratiate
himself with the prime minister of spain
this by the way many criticisms of
argentinians
myself being one but the whole thing
with the spanish is
the spanish love to separate themselves
from latin america and say yeah listen i
mean we speak spanish like central and
south america but
we're european so now alberto
comes in and he's trying to ingratiate
himself with the spanish prime minister
so he says hey
hey us too we're also not like these
people the mexicans
they're indians after all the brazilians
they came out of the jungle
but argentinians were dignified
we came from europe on boats and we had
european invest
this this is crazy and half my family
loves this guy uh it is it is bad
it is really really bad all right we're
standing by for joseph r biden jr
delayed by uh close to an hour if you
can imagine that
um okay
a few other super chats evan says sir i
receive my vaccine
but as an immuno-compromised person my
antibody response was only
347. masks are not just for
show that is true
jeremiah says if a third party had
policies you liked with a viable path to
public office
using something like ranked choice
voting would you vote for one absolutely
lock leviathan says if trump won he is
ineligible to run again right
not really because you're ineligible if
you serve two terms
i guess so yeah
former chat mod says check out david
pakman show glass
door ratings whatever's there is fake
i've never looked at it but i can assure
you it's fake
[Music]
okay so we are standing by for joe biden
um scheduled for about 50 minutes ago
delayed a little bit and we are going to
um
hear him answer questions something
which right-wingers insist he
you know can't do but he's going to do
it and he's going to do it again
let me get set up for that
[Music]
um this is in is this in brussels
yes brussels brussels absolutely
absolutely one of my favorite cities in
europe
um i've only been there once
but a great great place truly a great
place
and i hope to get back there soon
maybe even as soon as this summer who
knows
all right also thank you to coro
benicki who just subscribed with prime
and says thanks for the videos always i
work in healthcare finance
and it makes the workday go faster great
to hear i appreciate that you're new
member number 21 today
and it looks like some people are
getting banned but mostly it looks like
people are being nice in chat today
and we do have a helper in twitch chat
today our new intern
kate is around if you need help setting
up your amazon prime twitch prime
stuff and uh somebody got her a
membership and people are generally
being nice but one person did get banned
sadly
how might we realistically get to ranked
choice
individual states uh would have to would
have to do it and then you would have a
state level ranked choice
and then that would probably um
that would probably point in that
direction federally
oh pedro also was saying that the the
quote that alberto fernandez
actually read was wrong pedro says the
accurate pastas quote is
le mexicano de sienden de los artecas
meaning the mexicans descend from the
aztecs
peruano de los incas meaning the
peruvians from the
inca natives los argentina de la
hobartos and argentinians descend from
boats meaning they came over
uh presumably from europe is what that
means so he's not even really
representing the uh
the quota accurately i guess which is
not
a huge surprise i mean the guy is truly
gross
truly gross david do you hate leftists
no that's that's a weird question
really weird question my belief is that
uh this is going to be a very short
speech
followed by questions there is as you
can see the prompter is there
so if the prompter is there it's
probably because biden will will speak a
little bit first
although the wright believes biden needs
the prompter just to answer
questions but i've seen no evidence of
that whatsoever
um i don't know how long this is
expected to run
i would imagine not that long
that's uh that's my sense of it okay
dapper dave says stop wearing plaid in
june save it for the fall yeah i know
this was not the right shirt for today
and it's actually super hot so i may
roll my sleeves up
and i think i'm also going to crank up
the ac just a little bit
if uh if people will allow it
let's maybe let's go down like a degree
or two
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
yeah it's just a bit a bit uh
a bit warm here okay good
how much longer is joe biden's trip i'm
not sure i i think it's rapping
relatively soon i don't expect it to go
on much longer
he's been to uh england and
britain and the uk and
uh i expect that it is going to be
rapping
relatively soon uh
yes ro khanna will be with us on the
show tomorrow
that's always good if people have ques i
know there's like some drama with ro
khanna actually where all of a sudden
he's fallen out of favor
with some people on the left i don't
even understand what he did
but if people want to send me questions
you can send them to info
davidpakman.com rokhana congressman
rokhana will be joining us tomorrow
and then wednesday dr ashish jah from
brown university
we have questions about variants
vaccines the future of the pandemic
when whoever whatever country's going to
be able to get vaccinated
anything covered related with dr ashish
jaw um send it in send it in because he
i i expect that to be a really good
conversation
couple other clips i wanted to play for
you guys i don't know if i have time to
squeeze this in
but i did have one more clip alex jones
is now claiming he coordinated the
attacks
with help from the trump white house now
can we believe alex jones
i don't know but this is what he's
claiming take a look then the white
house told me three days before
we're gonna have you lead the march the
secret service
before trump finishes 30 minutes before
so we'll lead you to a point
take you out of the front row and leads
you to the place where they want you to
start the march
and trump will tell people go and i'm
going to meet you at the capitol
now if this is true obviously
it's outrageous at the same time alex
jones is a known and persistent liar
how has he not been arrested is he being
investigated you know a lot of this is
really not
making sense because if even a fraction
of that is true
um then you would you would think that
authorities would be
very much involved in figuring out what
if what if that is true
i don't know you tell me if we should
believe it and then you know when the
guy gets sued
then his lawyers show up and say oh he
plays a character on the show he's not
really saying
he's he's playing character it's
hyperbole it's exaggeration it's not
literally to be believed
and if what he's saying is true you
would think there would be some record
some phone records email records
uh whatsapp you know whatever you'd
think there would be there would be able
to be
something shown to to prove that um and
that's the yes people are pointing out
that's the art
it's the fox news defense or the tucker
carlson defense that's exactly right
they've used that now my promise to you
my friends that is
never an excuse you will hear from me if
i get in trouble for something i said
if it's wrong i'll come back and issue a
correction as i've done before
uh but you are never going to hear me
say guys what i said on the show was
just an
act that's not this show
that's not this show all right godzium
says via super chat my girlfriend says
hi
well hi to your girlfriend junie mcgraw
says are you by any chance worried that
joe manchin may
flip to gop gop if biden tries to pull a
bully pulpit on him
so i do think it's plausible that joe
manchin might eventually switch to being
a republican
i don't think it's biden uh trying to
strong-arm him
or negotiate with him that is going to
do it
yeah um
all right hold on looks like we're
getting an it we have an issue
apparently with someone
man people just can't behave in chat
just a lot of drama in chat
really strange
very strange stuff yeah um did i see the
trump video yeah
i saw it this is kind of edgy
actually i don't even i don't even know
there's there's a funny kamala trump
mashup that i don't even know if i
should play
let me see
[Music]
it's uh
i think there's a dog barking outside
too
[Music]
all right people want the clip this is
this is pretty cleverly done
i don't know how many people have seen
this
do not come do not come
i'm gonna come oh
man
[Applause]
anyway it's it's pretty freaking
cleverly done
it's cleverly done i don't know i for
some reason i thought it was a
vic burger clip to begin with but i
guess it's not
the cheering is what really makes it
yeah people are
rightly pointing out the comedic value
of the cheering
hey david have you heard about the
possible nuclear reactor leak in
china no i have not nuclear reactor leak
china
oh yeah no that actually that seems to
be a thing let's take a look at that
this could be a big deal
[Music]
edf examines gases built up
at chinese nuclear plant
oh hold on no i thought it was starting
french power group edf has begun
examination of a potential issue linked
to a buildup of inert gases
at its nuclear power station in china
though the company and its chinese
partners say the plant was operating
safely
cnn reported the u.s government spent
the week assessing report of a leak at
the taishan power plant in guangdong
province run by a joint venture between
edf and china general nuclear power
group so we don't know yet edf says the
built up
buildup of noble gases like krypton and
xenon which it said affected the primary
circuit of reactor number one of the
taishan plant was a known phenomenon
studied and provided for in the reactor
operating procedures all right so it
seems we don't really know too much
about it yet
um but we'll keep an eye on it do i
think biden travel was a good idea in
what sense
you mean covet wise or i mean i think
it's been fine
he's getting along with people far
better than trump did that's for sure
i want to say thank you to stephen
johnson steven just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com
and if you can imagine didn't even use
any coupon code
use no coupon code whatsoever just
paying full price
and heroic move that's for sure
appreciate that stephen curtis says
uh david help me settle a debate
the girlfriend and i are having which is
better in lasagna cottage cheese or
ricotta
is that real
[Music]
that can't possibly be real
[Music]
obviously it's ricotta
cottage cheese lasagna guys
is that even a thing i'm gonna look at
that up
cottage cheese lasagna
i love cottage cheese you know i mean
there's no question about it
there's okay i do see some recipes that
use cottage cheese
it doesn't seem like my thing oh it's a
midwest thing oh okay
yeah i tend to go more for the italian
style lasagnas
which are uh heavily ricotta-based
ricotta mozzarella right it's a mix i
love i love cottage cheese no i i have
no problem with cottage cheese
uh there's so many it's it's fantastic
but um
not a lasagna not a lasagna maria says
new member here hi david do you like the
band
pussyfur i couldn't tell you one song by
that band i really couldn't
curtis says dude it is and it sounds
disgusting
she seems to love it using your response
as supporting evidence thank you sir
um appreciate that yeah yeah no i mean
cottage cheese is great for
so many different things cottage cheese
with berries and a little bit of honey
on top
that's a great that's a great thing um
cottage cheese even cottage cheese on
toast
there's so many uses for cottage cheese
but um
lasagna is is not where i would think of
to start
dumping in cottage cheese it's just not
but
i am a total food libertarian people
should do whatever they want
if you want banana with green peas
and balsamic on it i don't care go ahead
and have it just don't force me to eat
it that's all i'm saying
hey david do you think we're seeing the
dying embers of trumpism with
lindel jones giuliani and without his
social media it will just die out it
doesn't appear to be
it doesn't appear to be and that's
that's a really scary thing
um they seem to the trumpians seem to be
almost completely in control of the uh
of the republican party at this point in
time
do i think 911 was a controlled
demolition
no no i do not think that
i do not think that am i being clear
enough that i don't think that guys
i hope i am um
david you should check them out do you
like tool same singer no i'm not a tool
guy
not a fan of tool not a fan of um
you know not a fan of really that type
of music not a nine inch nails guy
not a uh marilyn manson guy
um i'm not saying it's bad i'm just
saying it's not my thing this guy's this
is just opinion i'm not saying anybody's
wrong who likes it
i'm just saying it's not my thing that's
all
it's no big deal all right it looks like
we are getting very close to this press
conference now more than a full
hour late if you can imagine that
probably only another hour until joe
biden shows up
very strange very very strange
david do you the the band why
i can't i can't even parse that guys i'm
sorry
uh maria says it's okay we all have
flaws yeah i'm not a fan of like
super heavy metal i'm not a fan of
country
i'm not a fan of blue grass
i'm not a fan of death core
i'm not a fan of black metal
[Music]
um but other than that you know i'm
i'm a fan of a number of different
things here's a guy
on the stage that's a sign of something
the camera is getting a little bit of a
wobble
which i don't even know what it's a sign
of
[Music]
people seem very ready for joe biden
also children's music i just love just
kidding i really can't stand it
um rhythm and blues sure
sure sure
i'm not a fan of um what's the what's
the juggalo band
club the clown posse not a fan of that
yeah i consider that similar to um
i don't know i don't even know what uh
what genre that's considered to be alex
says my mother is a german foreigner and
uses cottage cheese in lasagna the only
way i had it growing up wow well
consider me informed now
um if people think it's a good idea i'm
not
against trying it maybe at some point in
the future
but it's not super super high on my list
my big thing is the no bake lasagna
noodles the last thing or
sorry the no boil lasagna noodles it if
you want to make a nice lasagna
and then first you've got to boil water
and cook the
the noodles before you can even put it
in the oven
i'm out guys that's just too much work
so i love the
no boil lasagna noodles that's a big
piece of advice nathan says sir
do you like things i like things things
are life
thank you sir yeah nathan that's that's
a good
summary of of recent super chats
david have you seen kevin paffraff is
running for governor of california
i'd be interested in hearing your
thoughts on his platform yeah he i was
on the kevin paffraff show not long ago
and i heard he's running i don't know
too much about it
and you know i'm not gonna pay too much
attention to candidates in california
until we know for sure that there's
going to be a recall
[Music]
it just seems like a weird thing to
focus too much on we covered that one
caitlyn jenner interview because it was
a
such a train wreck but um that's
probably
it ferret queen says hey david can you
please say hi to my soon to be husband
he's home with food poisoning and
another fan of yours wow sorry to hear
that
um ferret king and
feel better feel better tara says what
kind of music do you like david
like i said almost anything outside of
what i mentioned
i like alternative i like classic rock
i like r b i like pop i
like uh classical i like andean music
i like argentinian reggae i like
argentinian
ska i like um
you know so many different things
pusifer
is electronic music no rock okay all
right that's fine
peruvian flute music ethiopian jazz
i'm just not super familiar with some of
those soda stereo is a great band yep
absolutely
have you heard of the artist aries i
have not
do you like bad bunny oh yeah i don't
know i
i i'm into the latin trap genre
and i hope i'm right in saying bad bunny
is latin trap i'm not
i'm not super familiar with bad bunnies
discography
i'm familiar with a few songs some of
them are all right
yeah but la i'm not i'm not against it
there's a lot of good uh a lot of good
latin trap artists i know people like
anthony fantano
i can people tell me is anthony fantano
against latin trap
does he consider it a lower form of
music anybody know
[Music]
nobody knows okay
yeah uh whatever i don't know
david i'm 21 how do i figure out what i
want to do with my life every career i
choose has me going to college and in
stem
thank you well uh if that's interesting
to you then pursue that what i would say
is
don't worry too much about figuring out
exactly what you want to be doing long
term
at 21 it's the time to try different
things you have plenty of time
you could spend the next 10 years trying
stuff that doesn't work
and by the time you're 31 you'll know
more about what doesn't work for you
than most people ever will
and then you're still only 31 that's the
great thing so i wouldn't worry too much
about it
just try things if something seems
interesting try it
curtis says he's against anything that's
good who's he
fantano yeah i would try to limit the
amount of debt you go into in order to
try things that's a good
that's a good point i think from the
chat
that's a good point from the chat
definitely um
if you can avoid debt or significant
debt that's that's
i would prioritize that i would
prioritize that
um okay so joe biden is now a
70 minutes late we don't know why
it's very strange it's sort of
disrespectful
certainly to you fine folks i have
nowhere to go but do you find folks it
does seem to be sort of
disrespectful we um
what's an example of argentinian ska oh
all right i'll pull up a little
argentinian scar for you guys
let's see argentinian ska
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's a good example
[Music]
give you a little argentinian scar here
um
[Music]
yeah here's a little something this is a
great band i think i even actually
saw these guys live once
[Music]
this is a band called fabulous cadillacs
you don't want to mess with this guy i'm
telling you
[Music]
all right this is kind of weird but
let's skip ahead
[Music]
and if we could just like get into the
music it would be much better
[Music]
in a few minutes it should start
yeah i've definitely seen these guys
live
[Music]
these guys have some great shows
[Applause]
[Music]
this is scott right
[Music]
foreign
okay anyway so that's a band i like i
saw them live um
once when i was in argentina it was
pretty pretty awesome okay
um i want to say thank you to other
people who are sending me
messages david have you heard of the
aussie band king gizzard and the wizard
lizard
they are psych rock no i have not
scott says can't wait to see how doc
fauci is responsible for
a chinese nuclear meltdown are you
gifted with rhythm and movement on the
dance floor of course
juggalos are sweet decent people despite
their goofy aesthetic and need of a
shower
plus the icp are quite brilliant
businessmen i just said i don't like the
music i don't uh i have no
issue with anybody
susan says toronto loves you with a
really strong hundred canadian dollar
super chat thanks susan appreciate that
ryan says sorry to hear you're not a
juggalo mcl
anyway dp david lab leak coverage has
been driving me bonkers what percentage
sure are you that there's nothing to it
support an investigation
sorry to harp on it guys at this point i
have 10 clips about the lab league stuff
i am fine investigating anything people
want to investigate
but my point has been until we have
evidence that the most likely
explanation is something other than what
we currently believe it to be
we should not i'm just rolling up my
sleeves we should not
go out there and say it probably came
from the lab
until we actually have a reason to
believe that investigate whatever you
want
investigate whatever you want netanyahu
is the lead story on today's podcast so
if you want to hear me talk about
netanyahu out
which is great news it is in the first
segment of today's podcast and i
encourage you to check that out
download it uh it'll be out in about 90
minutes
so that's um something very very
exciting for a lot of people certainly
um let's see you know i'm seeing some
people
not really behaving too well in twitch
chat and even sending some
hostilities to our intern kate who's in
the chat you know so many people
on twitch have they know they have
amazon prime
and they want to sign up via twitch
prime and they just don't know how to do
it so
our intern kate is in the chat as tdps
kate helping people to sign up
and a couple people already got banned
for attacking her it's bizarre
but just remember if you have amazon
prime
you can take five bucks from bezos and
send them to us
it's free it costs nothing and if you
don't know how to do it
kate can help okay
jeez just like vicious
vicious attacks brutal
um yeah
we've been dropping ban hammers pretty
aggressively
pretty aggressively by the way thank you
to jso
bro for the twitch sub number 23 today
also thanks to maxi pad new member
number 24 today
strong also thank you thank you to
superman xi superman ix i don't know how
that's
supposed to be pronounced but i
appreciate that
um biden is still talking to president
turkish president
erdogan says stefan tosher
do we know that or is that just what uh
you were saying
do we actually know that for a fact
[Music]
doesn't seem that we do
[Music]
okay very weird
i can't tell if that that's like a
serious comment or not
let's see if i look on twitter let's see
if on my tweet feed
anyone is addressing that
[Music]
biden let's see here
i'm not seeing anything about that
rudy's tweeting about
flag day okay
no i'm not seeing anything about that
[Music]
a lot of tweets about bitcoin
what's going on with bitcoin price
[Music]
did something happen
it's back above 40k oh that's
interesting
one week one month so it's back above 40
for the first time i guess in about
two weeks not not the most exciting
thing really
but all right something to keep an eye
on
was in the german news a couple of
minutes ago
all right godric says david can you help
me
with my homework solve for x one half
plus x equals three all right let's see
if i can figure that out
take a look at this one half
plus x equals three so we want to
isolate x in order to do that we
subtract
one half from both sides half
plus x minus one half that's just x
three minus one half hold on three minus
one half
three minus one half carry
cosine three minus one half
i think that's x equals eleven 11d
all right guys see how quickly i did
that
fantano isn't against latin trap he
doesn't dislike
any particular genre he judges artists
and albums on a case-by-case basis
beautiful i like that
that's the right approach i would say i
want to say thank you to
the van der hell as well as ross
the boss 109 for subscribing with twitch
prime new members 26 and 27 today
very much appreciate that
um oh you know what it actually does
seem
like there's a major delay with biden
is it true that this could be another 90
minutes
[Music]
take a look at that biden
erdogan
[Music]
oh wow it really may be
[Music]
huh
[Music]
yeah it looks like it's going to be over
an hour wow okay
in that case let's just reset because i
mean i i have to start working on
tomorrow's show or there will be no show
i think what we'll do is we'll pause
this stream
and then i'll just reset and cut it
looks like it's gonna be a while yeah
yeah yeah yeah people are agreeing with
me
um okay yeah so let's just pause this
stream here
uh good sirs and then we'll just get
reset back up for when this thing is
actually going to start
all right um just just we're going to be
it's going to be a while and
at some point i actually do have a job
which is crazy and it's not even really
this
so i mean it's you know the broadcast
show and all of that stuff so
we'll be back i'll miss everybody and
then we'll we'll get reset back up very
embarrassingly late today